[Music]
david's gonna start us off in amarillo
texas
hi david how are you
pretty good dave how are you today
better than i deserve what's up well
uh
i have recently remarried about three
years ago
and uh was very near debt free and
my
wife after we got with i told my wife
before we got married we weren't gonna
have any debt
except the house and
so
anyway
uh on our first anniversary i bought her
a
sleep number bed which is very expensive
and i charged it well
now she she likes to spend money like
it's made out of water like there's an
endless supply
and
i can't get her to
to sit down with me and
and create a budget and and i you know i
would really like to do the financial
piece university with her
uh but
i just don't know how to
get her to agree to those things well
the first thing you don't do is say dave
ramsey said
whatever you've already did it didn't
you
yes sir yeah you turned me into a cuss
word man
you you wimp you blamed it on me and the
second thing is you can't tell your wife
okay this going into our my new marriage
this is gonna be a key priority for us
until the first big purchase and then
i'm gonna go ahead and just uh knock
down my own boundary and then get mad at
you for walking through that gate that i
opened up you can't do that
yeah so yeah i understand
what you've got to do is you have to
dial back because both of you engaged in
childish behavior
and we have to both dial back to adult
behavior
adults devise a plan and follow it
children
do what feels good
and so what you're discussing is the
symptom the symptom is overspending the
symptom is debt
the symptom is a sleep number bed you
financed a bit a bad man a bad
so you have to dial back and go those
are symptoms and the the problem that
caused those symptoms to occur
is
vision lack of it you do not have a
shared vision for your wealth in the
future and what your wealth will do for
you it will allow us to travel it will
allow us to buy this it will allow us to
be generous in this way and we have to
do
things to cause that wealth to happen
and one of those is avoiding debt going
forward and that includes me because i'm
a bonehead and i broke my own word here
you got to start with apologizing deeply
a deep bow and scrape
and beg for forgiveness and then say
but the reason i wanted us to do that
even though i screwed it up was because
i believe if we stay out of debt these
are the things that are going to happen
let's talk about why and where we're
going and changing our family tree and
retiring with dignity and being in a
position to be unbelievably generous and
those kinds of big things
then she can get on board and oh by the
way you get a vote and i get a vote we
both have a vote and we don't go against
that my wife and i were discussing a
major purchase this morning before i
left home
and she wasn't happy about it and i'm
really happy about it
and um
but later on but later on it got we got
happy you know and so it worked out but
we weren't go i wasn't going to go
forward with that until we're both
in agreement and it fits into our
overall plan yeah and i think it's
important
a gun or a truck could be yeah it could
be it could be um
he sidetracked me um so here's another
thing a conversation you can have after
the vision conversation is being curious
with yourself when you're about to buy
something both you and her
the question i always want to ask myself
for me it's eating for me it is i want
to skip a workout for me it's i'm not
going to check in with my wife on this
i'm just going to go do it
right when i'm about to make a behavior
that i know is going to cost me
downstream what's been transformative
for me is instead of getting mads of
getting frustrated is stopping and being
curious and asking myself what am i
trying to protect myself from what is
this amazon purchase what am i trying oh
i'm bored oh i had a a a tiff with my
six-year-old and i'm pouting and so i'm
gonna go buy some more i don't know
fishing line or something stupid that i
don't really need what am i doing this
stuff for and then that's always gonna
push me back to the vision right which
is oh we're doing this for this i'm not
going to hit it for this right i'm not
going to hit purchase i'm not going to
go buy this i'm not going to buy a 9
000 bed on credit
um because we have a different vision
for our life but the the
the most asked question since i started
the show 30 years ago how do i get my
spouse on board yep and number one
answer is don't
say dave ramsey said because nobody
cares what dave ramsey said it's got to
be about us it's got to be from inside
right yeah and no really the truth i
mean that's not me just being humble or
weird or something yeah i mean you know
at the end of the day your opinion for
your life is that you're the only one
gets a vote in your life imagine if she
i don't get a vote in your life if
sharon came to you and said dave uh my
friend dan says that i should hold your
hand more so i'm gonna start doing that
that wouldn't mean anything right but if
if my wife comes to me and says
hey i i want to start holding your hand
i mean like i thought like i want to get
closer to you that means something so
you always you number one you don't
blame it on me number two
there's a whole get out of that thing
here is so that right what's your so
that yes
it's so that we can be not broke anymore
and stressed it's so that we don't ever
act like
you know we're not we've both talked
about your parents are are pitiful yeah
we're sad about their financial
condition we don't want to be them when
we're old
it's so that we're going to avoid debt
so that we're not them we're going to
avoid debt so that we've got a pile of
money we send the kids to college with
any debt we want to
be so that we'd like to open a a
hospital in our neighborhood and drop 10
million dollars into that so that i
don't know what you're so that is but
you need to sow that because debt in and
of itself is not worth it that's right i
mean it's good it's good get out of debt
it's a good thing but the only reason we
want you to get out of that the reason
we teach you get out there so that yes
you get financial peace yes and so that
you can do things yes and you can say
when that kid comes to your door you
don't kind of find nickels of pennies
you can buy all the candy right you can
do those generous things man you can
just completely
buy out all the inventory of the girl
scout wouldn't that be fun that would be
fun just mess with her day and what
would be really great is to have
75 boxes of cookies and i'll try to
explain my wife i'm just doing a good
thing huh buy buy a single mama car yeah
exactly oh buy 10 on my car exactly you
know i mean change your life man
take that girl in the youth group and
pay for college but the problem is when
we get down into the weeds
it all comes down to a sleep number bed
becomes a math problem instead of a
heart it's a sleep number bed what what
what
yeah
i mean god i wish i could go back and
tell you all the stupid butt stuff
i have done with money and bought things
i have bought that are just hilariously
stupid
sleeping over bed wouldn't be on the
list but i've done some hilariously
stupid things